BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Broadcasting to you live from the Northeast Passage Communications Newsroom.
Today's date is October, Friday the 13th at 8 o'clock sharp.
And this is FUWAMOCO Morning.
Good morning world.
Good morning you out there.
I am not a chihuahua.
I am Fuwawa.
Fuwawa Abyssgard.
I'll be your host today, together with our team at Northeast Passage Communications.
Delivering you the hottest and the most leading news of the hour.
This is FUWAMOCO Morning.
Your news, our business.
Business as usual.
FUWAMOCO Morning is held every Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
Help me!
Here at the Northeast Passage Communications, we deliver you the news you need in order to go about your day with a protected smile because you know what you need to do to stay safe.
And hopefully, that will allow you to keep you and your feet grounded.
Please inform us of any breaking news with the hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Let nothing surprise us as we go about our business.
Now, we begin today's broadcast with some breaking news.
There have been reports of severe shortages worldwide of pon-de-ring mochi donuts.
Different from any other donut, which is a simple piece of dough that has been deep fried and has no relation to nuts, a pon-de-ring is made with glutinous rice flour and is chewy and pliable and loved by many.
Even dogs, man's best friend, have had a strange fascination with them, similar to their desire to chew on sticks from trees.
However, in recent months, the price of these donuts has exploded tenfold, creating a black market for these mochi donuts.
But only just now, have they almost completely disappeared.
Almost as if they've gone extinct.
No one can find a single pawn.
Other donut manufacturers have tried to pass off their own donuts as mochi donuts, but no custard nor apple fritter can or will sway the heart of the consumers.
With all that is going on in this world, can we simply stand idly by as we watch yet another beloved existence disappear?
This is the news.
It is our business.
Business as usual.
Moving on.
In the world of science, there has been a new breakthrough.
Seasonal allergies have plagued millions around the world for centuries without much relief.
There have been temporary solutions such as daily medicine, air purification, nasal sprays, the list goes on.
However, finally the sciences of the top universities worldwide have come together to unleash their knowledge.
And now, as if an exorcism, seasonal allergies have ceased to exist.
No more runny noses.
No more teary eyes.
And most thankfully,
Silence.
Why am I here?
There are no more sneezes any longer.
What's happening?
Nothing to surprise you or disturb you while you're reading quietly in the public library as one digilently does every day.
There is peace.
Peace in a world without sneezes.
Who knew advancements in science could go this far?
Thank you, doctors, for all your hard work.
What will they cure next?
This is the news.
It is our business.
Business as usual.
BAU BAU!
Now, for recent pop culture news.
Vtubers, also known as virtual TVtubers, have become all the rage with those who follow the most current trends in technology and music.
They sing, they dance, they play video games, and it's the ones from hololive Indonesia who will be having a big celebration.
Their 3D showcases.
Vesira Zeta, Kaila Kowalskia, and Kobo Kanaeru.
We'll be showcasing themselves in their 3D bodies this month, starting with Zetta, the mysterious 7th recruit of the Secret Archive Unit that has a full license to collect virtual data.
A full license to collect YOUR virtual data.
She'll be having her showcase on Sunday the 15th at 6am PT.
And you won't want to miss it or else.
Right?
You would never want to be left out of all the fun and entertainment that your friends are enjoying.
So, make sure to stay glued to your screen and enjoy all the TV tubers that hololive has to offer.
This is the news.
It is our business.
Business as usual.
Next, I would like to switch to our resident meteorologist, Mr. Perochini, for our weather forecast.
Perochini, you're live.
This is FUWAMOCO Morning, and I am Perochini, giving you all your real-time weather updates.
As almost everyone here knows, there has been some serious storm activity recently after that weather front settled in permanently one year ago.
Here is a viewer submitted video we received just moments ago.
Wow.
Looks like things might have calmed down a bit there.
That's a pretty nice drive to work.
Remember, when the rain falls, umbrellas and jackets are completely useless.
Please remember to do your part in saving the planet and forget those at home.
The best you can do is give yourself to the storm and become as wet as a dog.
Good luck out there folks.
This is business as usual.
Back to you, Fuwawa.
Thank you, Perochini, for the weather update.
Remember, you will get wet.
You cannot resist it.
This is the news.
It is our business.
Business as usual.
As we bring FUWAMOCO Morning to a close this Friday the 13th morning, we would like to remind you that this is a community-run show produced by the Northeast Passage Communications and you.
You, the viewer.
Our viewer.
We would like to remind you to send us your submissions with the hashtag FWMCMORNING and that you share your life with our other viewers just like you.
Now.
Getting an appropriate amount of exercise is key to a long life and walking outside
Walking outside can help promote a strong body.
It boosts both your cardiovascular as well as pulmonary health, reduces risk of heart disease and stroke, improves management of conditions such as hypertension, high cholesterol, joint and muscular pain or stiffness, and diabetes.
It is also proven that a walk outside can promote stronger bones and overall improve life balance.
Here are some viewers who are taking control of their physical health.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for that.
I feel much more inspired to go for a walk now.
You too.
Of course.
BAU BAU.
And finally.
BAU BAU!
We'd like to continue to our most popular segment.
Yes.
Our dog of today.
Yesterday.
Not tomorrow.
Soon you will find out the secret to its popularity.
Roll the tape.
Help me.
Why am I here?
Thank you for joining us for October Friday the 13th, FUWAMOCO Morning.
This, this is where we say goodbye for now, and maybe forever.
Goodbye, chito.
Goodbye, ponzu.
Goodbye, Bishop.
Goodbye, Stickboy.
Goodbye, Andy-chan.
Goodbye, Ricky.
And to every other viewer out there, you know what you need to do to protect your smile.
This was FUWAMOCO Morning, delivering you the hottest and the most leading news of the hour.
Your news.
Our business.
Business as usual.
Goodbye.
BAU!